there are dozens of division 1 football
prospects in the las vegas valley but
not many are built quite like gorman's
jake taylor the gale is as big and
strong as they come and as john tree
choses tonight he also has a future
pro's presence
he's both a nice kid
and a menacing man last time you see me
or anyone in the nation seen me play
it's my sophomore year i'm a senior now
obviously so that two years off of
preparation is very scary for everyone
who lines up against me at six foot six
290 pounds jake taylor is a tackle that
towers and powers the gorman machine he
looked 35 and he played like he's 35 man
he's a dog out there he opens holes and
you know that's what you know i got to
thank my alignment all my linemen are
great but
he's the one that makes me score jake
has been going to gorman games since
birth his grandma and mom are alumni so
is beau the big bro playing at ucla he's
the best person i've ever met
brother in all it's not being biased
he's the best person i've ever met he's
a great role model in the classroom
family member and obviously football
player some kids get recruited jake
selected after visiting alabama and
notre dame this summer the big man chose
boomer sooner this stadium is about
i want to say 10 000. when you add the
extra zero it's going to be a little bit
more pressure so
knowing that it's not as bad but it's
been some sleepless nights thinking
about the season school's turning up so
i'm getting used to it though taylor is
taking his talents from one football
powerhouse to another but if you think
this lyman's gonna lay low with his
laurels
you're gonna be highly surprised on
friday night 425 pushing 455 right now
on bench so uh that preparation the two
years are just grinding in the off
season just to put on the field it's
going to be scary this year gorman and
taylor take on anyone and everyone
beginning this friday john treach 8
sports now